Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
Merhabalar.
Hepimiz gelecekten, dijitalleşmeden,
inovasyondan bahsediyoruz
ve genelde de bunun
magazin boyutu konuşuluyor.
Böyle internette,
Twitter'da görüyorsunuzdur,
omurgası alınmış hayvanlar ama yürüyorlar,
insan gibi hareket eden robotlar,
bunları böyle koyup bu videoları
birbiriyle like yarışına
giren fütüristler,
konferanslarda bunları gösterip
konuşmalar yapan
zıp zıp zıplayan profesörler.
Sürekli işin magazin
tarafıyla ilgileniyoruz.
Biraz da kendi hayatımızı
nasıl etkileyecek onu düşünelim,
onu tartışalım istedim bugün.
Önce size yapay zekayla başlayacağım,
en çok kullanılan
böyle popüler kavramlardan biri.
İlk yapay zeka uygulamasını anlatacağım.
İlk yapay zeka uygulamasını Fransa'da
Gaspard de Prony isminde bir matematikçi
yapmış 1700'lü yılların sonunda.
1789'da Fransa'da
devrim olmuş biliyorsunuz
ve aristokrasiye son verilmiş,
aristokratların topraklarını
köylülere dağıtmaya karar vermişler.
Tabii büyük bir sorun ortaya çıkmış;
toprakların alanını hesaplamak
ve sahiplerine vermek gerekiyor.
Bu işi Gaspard de Prony'den istemişler.
Bir toprak parçasının alanını
nasıl hesaplarsınız;
eni, boyu, yüksekliği koyup
o lisede kullandığımız sinüsleri,
kosinüsleri kullanarak
trigonometri hesapları yaparak
alanları bulursunuz
ama bütün Fransa için bunu yapacaksınız.
Gaspard de Prony, sinüs ve kosinüslerin
hesaplarını tablolara koymuş
ve bu tabloların başına da,
aristokrasi kalkınca işsiz kalan
yüz tane kuaförü oturtmuş.
Demiş ki, "Siz tablolara bakın,
en, boy, yükseklik, alanı bulun
ve toprağı sahibine verin."
Kuralları koyan bir matematikçi,
uygulayan kuaförler.
Geçtiğimiz yüzyılda,
bilgisayar teknolojisi geliştikçe
o kuaförlerin yaptığı işleri
bilgisayarlara yaptırmaya başladık.
Hesapları bilgisayarlar yapmaya başladı
ama son 10-15 yıldır çok daha farklı
bir şey oluyor arkadaşlar.
Bilgisayarlar artık veriye bakıp
verideki örgüleri tespit edip
kuralları da koyuyorlar.
Yani sadece kuaförün işini yapmıyorlar,
Gaspard de Prony'nin işini de yapıyorlar.
Mesela telefonla konuşuyorsunuz,
sesinizi anlayıp
ne dediğinizi anlayan telefonlar.
Fotoğrafları internete koyuyorsunuz,
fotoğrafta kimin olduğunu
anlayan sistemler.
Bunların hepsi veriye bakıp
kuralları koyan sistemler.
Şimdi ilk defa sadece o matematik
bilmeyen kuaförlerin değil,
matematikçilerin de ve ona benzer
diğer beyaz yakalıların da işlerinin
bilgisayarlar tarafından
yapıldığı bir çağda yaşıyoruz
ve tabii ki bu ekonomiyi
çok köklü bir şekilde değiştirecek.
Hatta değiştiriyor bile.
Bir tablo göstereceğim size.
Son 10 yıl içinde dünyanın en değerli
beş şirketi nasıl değişti, bunun tablosu.
2006 yılında ve 2017 yılında,
dünyanın en değerli beş şirketini
görüyorsunuz ekranda.
On yıl önce aslında Microsoft dışında
dünyanın en değerli beş şirketi,
bankalar ve petrol şirketleriydi.
Bugün onların hiçbiri bu listede değil.
Onların yerine dört tane şirket geldi:
Apple, Google, Facebook ve Amazon.
Bu dört şirket de yapay zeka kullanıyor,
çok fazla veri topluyor ve bu veriye
dayanarak kuralları koyuyor.
Son 10-15 yılda bütün hayatımızı
değiştirdi bu şirketler.
Ben kendi hayatımı biraz düşündüm,
nasıl değişti hayatım diye.
İlk bunlar arasında kullanmaya
başladığım Google olmuş,
o zaman 2000'li yılların başıydı,
üniversitede öğrenciydim Ankara'da ODTÜ'de
ve ilk defa ödevleri yaparken
çok kolay bir yöntem tespit ettim,
Google'a her şeyi yazıp
cevabını buluyorduk.
O günden beri neyi merak etsek
karımıza kocamıza patronumuza
soramayacağımız şeyleri,
hatta onları sorduğumuzu bilmelerini
bile istemeyecekleri şeyleri
Google'a soruyoruz.
Google, dünyada herkesin
neyi merak ettiğini biliyor.
Sonra okulu bitirdim, işe girdim
Rekâbet Kurulu'nda çalışıyordum.
Facebook'la tanıştım,
yeni bir dünya açıldı önümde
çünkü tanıştığım herkesin
fotoğraflarını görebiliyordum,
bütün geçmişlerini
ne yapıyorlar öğrenebiliyordum.
Şimdi o fotoğrafları biliyorsunuz
hatıra diye Facebook geri gönderiyor.
Şimdi fotoğrafları Instagram'a koyuyoruz
ama Instagram'ı da Facebook aldı
ve Facebook dünyada
kimin kimle arkadaş olduğunu
ve ne yaptığını
herkesten daha iyi biliyor.
Sonra 2008 yılında Amerika'ya gittim,
Amerika'da Uluslararası
Kalkınma okuyordum,
bizim sınıfımızda 25 farklı
ülkeden öğrenci vardı.
25 farklı ülkeden öğrencinin
hepsi, ben de dahil,
gider gitmez ilk iş olarak
birer Apple iPhone aldık.
Sonra Türkiye'ye geldim yaz tatilinde
arkadaşlarıma iPhone'umu göstereceğim diye
burada da herkes iPhone almıştı.
O günden beri neredeyiz, ne konuşuyoruz
hepsini aslında iPhone biliyor.
En son bunların arasında Amazon'la
tanıştım Amerika'dan döndükten sonra,
o zaman dış politikayla ilgili
çalışıyordum Ankara'da
ve yabancı kitapları
getirtmek sorun oluyordu,
istediğim zaman istediğim kitabı
getirtemiyordum, bir Kindle aldım.
Kindle'da kitabı indirdiğiniz anda
kitabı okumaya başlayabiliyorsunuz
ve siz hangi kitabı indiriyorsunuz,
neresini okuyorsunuz,
nerede canınız sıkılıyor bırakıyorsunuz,
Amazon bunların hepsini takip edebiliyor.
Sadece benim değil, milyarlarca
müşterisinin ne aldığını takip edip
bunun üzerine
yeni iş modelleri geliştirebiliyor
ve bu sayede, bu şirketler
kendi bulundukları alanlarda
tekel hâline geliyorlar.
Ne demek tekel olmak;
mesela Coca Cola beğenmezseniz
Pepsi içersiniz,
Pepsi beğenmezseniz
ayran içersiniz, su içersiniz,
kullandığınız arabadan
memnun değilsinizdir
mesela Ford beğenmiyorsanız
Volkswagen kullanırsınız,
Volkswagen beğenmiyorsanız
motorsiklet kullanırsınız,
gidersiniz taksiye binersiniz
ama internette Google dışında
gidip soru sorabileceğiniz bir adres yok
çünkü bu saatten sonra hiçbir şirketin
Google kadar çok veri toplayıp
o yapay zeka uygulamalarını geliştirmesi
ve işletmesi mümkün değil.
Kimsenin Google'ın karşısına
çıkması mümkün değil
ve bugün ne kadar böyle bol bol
pohpohlansa, devlet destekleri verilse,
paralar saçılsa bile girişimci olmak
her zamankinden daha zor.
Hele hele bu dört şirketin
bulunduğu alanların birinde.
Bakın mesela Instagram'ın hikâyesini
buradaki genç arkadaşlarımız
benden daha iyi bilirler,
Instagram ilk çıktığında
kaybolan fotoğraflarla çıktı değil mi,
fotoğrafı gönderiyorsunuz
hemen kayboluyor.
Ne oldu, birkaç ay içinde aynısını
Instagram yaptı Snapchat'in yaptığını,
pardon Snapchat'in
aynısını Instagram yaptı.
Artık Instagram'a o kadar alışmışım ki
ben de Instagram diyorum.
Ne yaptı Snapchat; videolar çıkardı,
gönderiyorsunuz kayboluyor story dediler,
aynısını Instagram yaptı.
Ne yaptı Snapchat?
Yeni bir şey yapalım dedi,
bu sefer fotoğafların üstüne
garip garip şekiller çıkartmaya
başladı, filtreler yaptı.
Aynısını Instagram yaptı.
Ne yapsa, Instagram
bir adım önde aynısını yapıp
daha hızlı bir şekilde
daha çok müşteriye götürebiliyor.
Bu şirketlerin karşısında yeni bir iş
geliştirmek her zaman olduğundan daha zor.
Peki bu şirketler
bu kadar çok değer yaratıyor,
acaba ne kadar istihdam yaratıyor?
Bir de isterseniz ona bakalım.
Şimdi bir tablo daha hazırladık.
Burada, son 10 yılda yapılan birkaç tane
teknoloji satın almasını görüyorsunuz.
İlki Google'ın Youtube'u alması.
Google, Youtube'u aldığında
Youtube'da 65 kişi çalışıyordu
ve 1.65 milyar dolar verdi.
Yani kişi başına 25 milyon dolar verdi.
Tersinden bakarsanız Youtube'da
25 milyon dolar değer oluşturmak için
1 kişi çalışıyordu.
2012'de Instagram satıldığında,
75 milyon dolarlık değer
oluşturmak için 1 kişi çalıştırıyordu.
2014'de Whatsapp satıldığında,
345 milyon dolar değer
oluşturmak için 1 kişi çalıştırıyordu.
Şimdi burada yaklaşık 2000 kişiyiz.
Whatsapp, Instagram, Youtube;
bu şirketlerde çalışan eşi dostu,
arkadaşı kardeşi akrabası olan var mı?
Yok, bir küçük el kalktı orada.
Tamam bir kişi varmış, iki oldu.
2000 kişide 2 kişi.
Peki eski ekonomi şirketlerinde
Ford'da, Arçelik'te, Renault'da
buralarda çalışan eşi dostu olan var mı?
Hepimizin var
çünkü bu şirketler, değeri
istihdamdan değil veriden sağlıyor.
Bakın az önce Ford dedim,
Ford 200 bin dolar değer
yaratmak için 1 kişi çalıştırıyor,
Facebook 20 milyon dolar değer
yaratmak için 1 kişi çalıştırıyor.
Yani 100 kat daha az istihdam sağlıyor.
Peki istihdam nerede artıyor?
Çok ilginç bir yerde artıyor,
az önce Gaspard de Prony'nin
aristokrasi bitince işe aldığı
kuaförlerden bahsetmiştik.
Son 5 yılda Türkiye'de
10 binden fazla kuaför açılmış.
Sadece kuaför değil;
şoför, bebek bakıcısı, çocuk bakıcısı.
Bakın çocuklara bakacak bakıcıyı
Türkiye'de bulamıyoruz,
Kırgızistan'dan Özbekistan'dan, paranız
varsa Filipinler'den bakıcı getiriyoruz.
Böyle insan ilişkilerine dayalı
ama bir yandan da emekliliği olmayan,
sosyal sigortası olmayan
küçük esnaflık işleri bir tarafta büyüyor.
Öbür taraftaysa, dijital ekonomide
bizim anladığımız anlamda
beyaz yakalı işler azalıyor.
Yıllarca hep iş bilenin
kılıç kuşananın diye büyüdük,
bir konunun uzmanı olalım,
onu öğrenelim onu yapalım dedik.
Annemiz babamız bize "Aman," dedi
"maymun iştahlı olma, sebat et
bir yerde çalış, bir işin uzmanı ol."
Şimdi size çok önemli
bir şey söyleyeceğim.
Eğer yaptığınız işi
annenize anlattığınızda
10 dakika içinde
ne yaptığınızı anlayabiliyorsa
büyük bir ihtimalle önümüzdeki
10 yıl içinde işsiz kalacaksınız.
(Alkış)
Çünkü ya sizin yaptığınız işi
yapay zeka yapmaya başlayacak,
ya sizden daha ucuza daha iyi yapan bir
uzman dünyanın başka bir yerinde bulunacak
veya sizin şirketiniz Apple'ın, Google'ın,
Amazon'un taşeronu hâline gelecek.
Ne yapacağız peki?
Bir alternatif okula dönmek,
yeniden okumak
ama burada epey
öğrenci arkadaşımız da var,
acaba onların okulları bu
dijital çağı hazırlayabiliyor mu?
Pek zannetmiyorum çünkü akademisyenler,
üniversite hocaları
genelde birbirleriyle konuşmaya
önem veriyorlar,
piyasayla konuşmaya önem vermiyorlar.
Benim annem babam da
üniversite hocası, oradan biliyorum.
Ne yapacağız peki?
Kendi kendimizi kurtaracağız.
Ben iki sene önce
General Electric'te işe girdim.
İstanbul'da bir Amerikan şirketi,
büyük bir şirket
ve bana ünvan olarak
inovasyon başkanı diyorlar.
Böyle dedikleri zaman biraz gülüyorum,
bir fıkra var çünkü aklıma o geliyor belki
siz de biliyorsunuzdur papağan fıkrası.
Üç tane papağanı
pazarda satıyormuş bir adam.
Önce sağdakinin fiyatını sormuşlar,
bu demiş 100 lira.
"Niye 100 lira?" demişler,
"Bu İngilizce uzmanı, İngilizce biliyor
o yüzden 100 lira," demiş.
Soldakinin fiyatını sormuşlar,
"Bu 200 lira," demiş.
"Niye?" demişler,
"Bu hem İngilizce hem Arapça biliyor,
ikisinin de uzmanı, o yüzden 200 lira."
"Peki bu ortadaki ne kadar?" demişler.
"O 1000 lira," demiş.
"Oha!" demişler.
"1000 liraya papağan mı satılır!
Bunun ne özelliği var?"
"Vallahi" demiş, "onun ne uzmanı
olduğunu ben de anlayamadım
ama diğer ikisi ona
başkanım diyor," demiş.
(Kahkahalar)
(Alkış)
Şimdi aslında bu papağanlar
işgücü piyasasının dinamiklerini
çoğu insandan daha iyi anlamışlar.
Ne yapacağız,
nasıl kurtaracağız kendimizi?
Ben gittiğim okullarda
edindiğim bilgilerden çok,
en çok kazandığım şeyin oradaki
arkadaşlıklar olduğunu düşünüyorum,
orada tanıdığım
insanlar olduğunu düşünüyorum
çünkü o insanlara baka baka,
o arkadaşları takip ede ede,
sorular sorarak,
ne yaptıklarını merak ederek,
biraz dedikodu yaparak dünyada
yeni neler oluyor öğrenebiliyorum
ve yeni şeyleri deneyebiliyorum.
Yeni tecrübeler edindikçe
bu tecrübeleri bir araya getirip
yepyeni fikirler ortaya çıkarmak,
yepyeni işler yapmak mümkün oluyor.
Aslında yapay zekanın yapamadığı,
en önemli insani özelliğimiz de
dedikodu yapmak, soru sormak,
merak etmek öyle değil mi?
Ve inovasyon denen şeyin de
esas kaynağı aslında bu.
Şimdi size birkaç tane örnek vereceğim,
böyle inovasyonlar yapan kişiler tarihten.
Bir tanesi az önce
bahsettiğim Gaspard de Prony,
iyi bir matematikçi
ve mühendistir diye anlatmıştım
ama babası çok ısrar ettiği için
hukuk fakültesi bitirmişti
ve herhâlde hukuk okumasaydı,
o kadastro işlerini de yapamazdı,
hangi toprağın kime ait
olduğunu tespit edemezdi.
Farklı farklı yerlerden
öğrendiklerini bir araya getirdi.
İkinci örnek Benjamin Franklin, Amerika
Birleşik Devletleri'nin kurucularından.
İyi bir siyasetçi
ama siyasetçi olmadan önce
iyi bir mucitti,
paratoneri bulmuştu mesela.
Şimdi hâlâ bugün kullandığımız
uzak ve yakın gözlüğü bulmuştu.
İyi bir girişimciydi, Amerika'ya
matbaayı getiren adamlardan biriydi
ama hepsinden önemlisi
Amerika bağımsızlığını ilan ettiği zaman,
İngiltere'yle savaşa girmişti
Amerika biliyorsunuz,
o zaman Amerika'nın Paris'teki
temsilcisiydi ve ne yaptı biliyor musunuz,
bu bilim dünyasından elde ettiği
kredibilite ve çevre ile
Fransız kralı ile arkadaş oldu
ve kralı Amerika'nın yanında
savaşa girmeye ikna etti.
Amerika o sayede İngiltere'yi yenip
bağımsızlığını kazanabildi.
Şimdi diyeceksiniz ki
bunlar tarihten örnekler,
bizimle bir alakası yok,
biz bunu yapamayız
ama aslında bizim de tarihimizde
iyi bildiğimiz ve çok
sevdiğimiz bir örnek var.
19. yüzyılın sonunda
Osmanlı İmparatorluğu dağılıyordu
ve Osmanlı İmparatorluğu'nda
birçok yetenekli subay vardı.
Aralarından sadece bir tanesi modern
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti'ni kurabildi:
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk.
Neydi Atatürk'ü bu kadar özel kılan?
Atatürk sadece iyi bir asker değildi;
aynı zamanda iyi bir tarihçiydi,
iyi bir dil bilimciydi.
Cumhurbaşkanı olduktan sonra
liseler için matematik kitabı yazmış,
matematiğe ve eğitime
ilgi duyan bir adamdı.
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk 38 yaşında
Kurtuluş Savaşı'nı başlattığı zaman,
daha önce beş farklı yerde
Sofya'da, Berlin'de, Libya'da,
Şam'da, Erzurum'da görev yapmış
bir askerdi ve 5 dil biliyordu.
O kadar çok farklı tecrübeyi
bir araya getirip
modern Türk Cumhuriyeti'ni tasarladı ki
ancak böylelikle bu inovasyon mümkün oldu.
Öyle inovasyon dediğiniz şey aslında
laboratuvarda yapılan bir şey değil,
siyasette de tarihte de inovasyon var
ve hep farklı farklı tecrübeleri,
birikimleri bir araya getirerek oluyor.
En son örneğin Elon Musk,
daha önce Türkiye'ye de geldi
geçen sene oradan hatırlarsınız,
herhâlde günümüzdeki en önemli
girişimcilerden ve inovasyonculardan biri.
Ne yaptı Elon Musk?
PayPal diye bir şirket kurdu
arkadaşlarıyla, bir ödeme sistemi şirketi
ve o şirketi sattılar, dağıldılar.
Aralarından bu büyük grubun içinden bir
tek Elon Musk üç tane daha şirket kurdu,
hepsi milyar dolardan
fazla para ediyor bugün.
Bir tanesi Tesla, bir araba şirketi.
Bir tanesi SpaceX,
uzaya füze gönderen bir şirket.
Bir tanesi de Solar City,
güneş enerjisi sistemleri yapıyor.
Hepsi birbirinden farklı işler yapıyor
ama Elon Musk birindeki mühendisliği
öbürüne uygulayarak,
birindeki müşteriye diğer ürünü satarak
birindeki tasarım tecrübesiyle
diğer ürünü geliştirerek
bütün bu işleri
bir arada yönetmeyi başarıyor.
O yüzden de bu farklı tecrübeleri
bir araya getirdiği için
dünyanın en önemli girişimcilerinden
ve inovasyoncularından biri oluyor.
Şimdi bütün bu dört isme baktığınız zaman,
Gaspard de Prony, Benjamin Franklin,
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk ve Elon Musk,
hepsinin bir tane ortak özelliği var.
Hiçbir zaman engellere takılmamaları,
cesur olmaları ve denenmeyeni denemeleri.
Şimdi bizim de önümüzde
iki tane yol var arkadaşlar;
ya az önce o gösterdiğim tabloda
Whatsapp'ta çalışan 55 kişi vardı,
onlardan biri olacağız, yani dünyada
bir konuyu en iyi bilen adam olacağız,
ben onu olamıyorum
ya da böyle farklı farklı
tecrübeler elde edip
bu tecrübeleri bir araya getirip
yenilikler yapacağız.
Kendi yolumuzu kendimiz çizeceğiz.
Şimdi bu dijital çağ aslında
sorulmayanı sormak,
denenmeyeni denemek
ve gidilmeyen yoldan
gitmek için en uygun zaman.
Hepinize çok teşekkür ediyorum,
bayramınız kutlu olsun.
(Alkış)